we can be glad to have so many people in
the White House and in government and in
general so willing to help reporters by
providing them information especially
about our new incompetent president but
also about other government activities
what is the military doing what is the
NSA doing etc however there are lots of
journalists that are increasingly afraid
of the future and their ability to keep
their jobs in the Trump era as leaker
investigations are becoming more and
more aggressive
connecting anonymous sources and
handling classified information by media
outlets is getting riskier every day
Donald Trump remember has publicly
called for the prosecution of Whitehouse
leakers remember for example when he
tweeted this spotlight has finally been
put on the low-life leakers they will be
caught
Trump has previously called for Edward
Snowden to be killed with Trump of
course there's always a double standard
it's not our focus today but remember
that Donald Trump did inappropriately
give classified information to Russian
diplomats one of whom is believed to be
a by US intelligence to be a Russian spy
recruiter named Sergei kis lyac but
let's put that aside for now we're not
talking about the hypocrisy today
although we always could
Donald Trump has even publicly attacked
the FBI and compared them to Nazis for
allowing leaks tweeting quote
intelligence agencies should never have
allowed this fake news to quote leak in
to the public one last shot at me are we
living in Nazi Germany and we know that
behind closed doors Donald Trump
allegedly asked former FBI director
James Comey to imprison leakers maybe
we'll learn more about that tomorrow
when James Comey testifies in front of
the Senate Intel committee attorney
general jeff Sessions has also been
really vocal about his opposition to
leakers he is pushing the FBI to be more
proactive in investigating them and New
York Times reporter Adam Goldman who had
his phone records secretly obtained by
the Justice Department during a leak
investigation said to CNN quote this is
a tough operating environment there is a
chill for sure we'll see how bad it gets
so what's the latest on this war against
leakers Monday the Justice Department
announced its first use under the trump
administration of the Espionage Act they
will be charging intelligence contractor
employee leaker reality ly winner for
leaking classified NSA documents to the
intercept about Russia hacking voting
systems in the United States a low-level
employee like winner will not have the
immunity of elites like former CIA
director David Petraeus did the Obama
administration pressed more Espionage
Act charges than all other presidents
since 1945 combined but the Trump
administration could surpass that Pat
because the climate is getting worse and
I've talked about this before when you
talk about going after WikiLeaks for
publishing information that they did not
illegally obtain that was handed to them
that is the crossing of a sort of red
line when it comes to a law enforcement
against leakers you can't go up to the
journalists who just report that
information from the leaker themselves
and that's what the Trump administration
is trying to do these days that's
exactly right and on the condition of
anonymity there's a Washington reporter
who said to CNN quote I think that the
unknown for us as national security
reporters is what are they willing to do
how far are they willing to go outside
the lines to clamp down on things that
they don't like another anonymous
reporter speaking to CNN said quote we
noticed that after we came to the White
House with a story they didn't like they
asked us to circle back to our sources
before publication to do a final fact
check we don't know what their
intentions were but we were concerned
that it was a trick to try to get us to
light up the phone networks in the Intel
community what's the bigger picture of
this it's part of Donald Trump's efforts
to control the media his claims about
fake news try to keep anything from
getting
now and if it does call it fake or talk
about the immorality of the people
reporting on it government officials
have freedom of speech talking about
embarrassing things that Donald Trump
does in the White House without
disclosing something that's classified
is completely legal and yet they are
creating a climate of fear and it's
translating to reporters and we should
all be worried about it because right
now maybe you don't care if you're at
rumpus because you're trying to prevent
negative news about Donald Trump but
this is a systemic threat to press
independence and even though it might
benefit conservatives right now it won't
always yeah exactly I mean Donald
Trump's credibility has been questioned
on a number of issues but especially
when it comes to leaks because when it
came to Hillary Clinton he invited them
he said that we love WikiLeaks he wanted
Russian hackers to find the 30,000
missing emails but now that he's the guy
in charge there only can be bad for him
I totally agree and listen I'm a
progressive right there's no doubt that
this is an opinion program but both
sides do this double standard when it
comes to leaks when the content of the
leaks is bad for you you focus on the
fact that there were leaks and going
after the leakers when the content of
the leaks is good for you you just talk
about the content of the leaks you don't
care where it came from both Democrats
and Republicans different on many issues
similar on many issues the double
standard around content versus sources
on leaks is one that we've been very
very critical of but I'll tell you over
the long run everybody loses
if we lose press freedom and I
understand the concern of many of the
reporters and commentators that are out
there I'm on Twitter talk to me about
this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show
is on Twitter at David Pakman show
today's program sponsored in part by tag
adapt the hosting specialists offering a
range of affordable and flexible hosting
packages including dedicated VPS and
cloud server options custom server
solutions and UK colocation services
tailored to your business or project
taga dev has over 70% of their business
coming from repeat orders from existing
customers or recommendations from
existing customers and this is really
testament to the support that they give
their customers they have an average
Trustpilot review rating of excellent at
nine point seven out of ten with more
and more people interested in moving
their businesses and projects to the
cloud taga deb are currently offering a
ten british pound free credit about
twelve or thirteen US dollars to all new
customers signing up to give you a
chance to try their services you can
take advantage of this offer by going to
sign up CagA Deb comm slash TDPS that
sign up da ga da b.com slash T DPS